good to see you Ernie John some bearing
gifts oh my gosh that's a nice paper bag
well you have a very okay so here's your
NBA auntie
very good nice trucker look yeah this is
some type of a t-shirt now normally
shouldn't you have to fire it out of a
cannon via NBA guys and here's what does
that say by the way does it just is it
pretty not NBA on TNT on TNT and this
could work out well then that's a box it
looks like this is valuable in this is
that a bobblehead of something it is the
bobblehead set and I don't know here can
hand it to me I will try there's a
Styrofoam city this is the set of the
four of us oh my gosh
this is gonna go on the Rich Eisen show
studio for sure I'm not oh my gosh there
we go let's snap any heads off oh my god
oh my word
yes look at this folks I'm the one
second from the right
or now second from the left by the way
the the hairline on this is particularly
impressive
yeah that's they're a little kind I know
that's trust me I understand what that
it there we go
there you go so I hope you enjoy them I
can't wait to take this home yeah thank
you for that thank you for bringing
gifts certainly thank you it's been
great here oh yeah I mean yeah I mean
you're here at our place and we thought
it was only appropriate that we that we
give you what a spot I mean when did you
first walk into this campus here Ernie
it'll be 30 years ago in July 9 1989
and we had like one main building where
you could still find Ted Turner in those
days that right yeah the main building
out there that has the fountain in front
and has the columns and then it just it
grew and I it's out of control but we
have I think we have the greatest studio
set up anywhere and and just happy to
have you happy to have you down here to
check it out we love it we've been we've
made to been made to feel right at home
and you know hopefully with whatever is
going on
synergy wise between Turner and the
parent company of this show hopefully
this is just the beginning of a very
long and beautiful let's hope so yes be
fine for sure um and so having a Super
Bowl in this town as well that's the
second one that has been here there's a
transform of town do you see it you feel
it or what here's the thing about any
time there's a Super Bowl in Atlanta the
first thing you worry about is the
weather right and then wouldn't you know
this week we had these dire predictions
of oh it's gonna snow it's gonna ice my
kids didn't go to school on Tuesday and
you know woke up it was 45 degrees and
then and what and then when it was all
supposed to hit it was about 38 degrees
but the kids were happy
it was beautiful though yeah nothing
happened no I know but things have
happened here in the past I know the
Super Bowl was very much a weather sir
yeah so I could have almost guaranteed a
nice storm this week with the Super Bowl
here but it didn't happen so it's gonna
be great it didn't happen at all and
I've not been in the new building it's
gorgeous I'm told
oh it is it's it's outstanding I was in
there for the very first game that was
played Alabama against FSU I was there
for the national championship game I
know you're a Georgia guy I doubt hurt
that hurt and then I was there for the
SEC Championship this year I'm kind of
tired of watching that movie yeah Miss
Georgia beats the dog out of Alabama for
almost the entire time and then it
doesn't happen but now he got Sony
Michele for the Patriots in this game
yes and he got turd Todd Gurley yeah you
know it's just it's just the Georgia
bloodline of world-class athletes I know
Ernie Johnson Sony Michele look Terrell
Davis in all honesty in all honesty I
had one one year of playing at the
University of Georgia I mean so I played
baseball there my freshman year I walked
on as a freshman and was told to walk
off as a sophomore but but I had that
one glorious year of wearing the red and
black and I'll never forget it what'd
you hit I was 2 for 18 I was 2 for 18 at
the dish with one career RBI one career
and it happened at the University of
Tennessee second game of a doubleheader
for 28 in the afternoon partly cloudy
skies temperature
about 63 but aside from that I don't
really remember
did you lace one in the gap no I was
left-handed hitter and I took one the
other way over the shortstop said
knocked in the go-ahead run which would
have which was gonna give us the SEC
Division title and then somebody for
Tennessee had a grand slam in the bottom
of the last inning we lost see you were
also I almost got in the red and black
student newspaper as the guy was a gig
with the game winning he almost sound of
a Frankie Cabrera mom yeah very very
very close very very close yeah
did you ever were you here when when
Turner had the NFL well yeah I worked I
worked a Sunday nitro in nitro right
yeah I had various roles I I was in the
studio I was in the studio when it
started with Ken Stabler Oh which was it
was it was the greatest it was the
greatest and and snake was just the
greatest guy in the world we'd all show
up to watch all the games you know at
you know we'd probably gather about
10:30 or 11:00 watching pregame watch
the games snake would come in you know
about 3:00 in the afternoon he said he
said I don't know what time I got in
last night EJ but the newspaper hit me
in the head so it was he was he was the
greatest and so I went from that to
being like on the you know at the site
of the game kind of and I did a little
bit of sideline and I did a pre and a
post game show from the field yeah but
yeah we had we had the NFL was the best
game that you had I mean he recall that
who we had the Jeff George game remember
the Jeff George game in Atlanta he and
June Jones got into it oh yeah we had we
had that so you were the sideline
reporter for that one man yeah you were
that but did you get in there see what
was him you know it was like one of
those things where you woke up Monday
morning said how the heck did I miss
that
mmm that's probably why my NFL career
ended not what we had a game for
Thursday night year was a Saturday night
game over so we as we called it the
Saturday night edition of Thursday Night
Football which you know people kind of
have make sense the TV guys don't
exactly right but everyone else they're
like what that was the game turned out
to be Bill Parcells last win is a head
coach beat the Falcons
where I'm on the sidelines of that game
I was doing the sidelines but are
getting set to do the halftime and a
member of Jim Morris staff comes running
up to me say do you have video of tio
spitting at the Angelo Hall and we're
like well in the same way that you might
have been like what what was going on
with Jeff George and June Jones I'm like
what are you talking about
they were hopping mad DeAngelo Hall was
hopping mad and sure enough taro Owens
came by our set postgame as the guest
and as if that wasn't awkward enough
Steve Mariucci who is we all know
benched him for going to the Dallas star
had not spoken to tio in years he was
who the guest he was the analyst nice
and everyone was volunteering to give up
their seat for that postgame interview I
was conducting and should tio flat out
admitted Yahoo spin at one of those and
we'll be right back I know and we'll be
right exactly that's always a good
fallback that's right always be ready to
say that well be right back I've always
told my aunt I've always told analysts
that I'm doing if you ever have any
trouble the safe words are back to you
rich
yeah those are the Safeway I'll take him
there any trouble on there for you do
you have any of those moments of your
career we had we had one with with Chuck
amazingly but he had he had said
something and I don't want to start a
big thing because I remember but I know
he had he had had a couple of things to
say about PETA at one point because the
league was thinking about going to well
all leather but going away from a
leather basketball and Charles came out
at halftime and just and we're live and
he slowly unwraps a hamburger
and I'm like Chuck I can't help but see
since I just want those people at Peter
to know that animals are good for two
things eaten intestine and I was like
Kenny help you know that was like man
there was like in Charles first or
second year with us but yeah it happens
every now and then and and and there you
just hope that you just hope that
sometimes it's not gonna be guilt by
association I know he said it but you're
all gone all right but you're so great
at this too I mean and then and Ernie
Johnson here on the rich eyes at you in
a Honda inside a report we'll talk some
NBA dick and a quick second but this is
what you're great at and that's what's
so great about the show that you do up
the hall from here is that it's natural
it looks like your show meeting is on
television that what you're doing sure
it's produced but you are just being
yourselves and you allow these guys to
be themselves and when it does need some
sort of corralling you corral it and at
times you know when to let everybody go
to let them be themselves and that that
is an art sir and I want to point that
out well you you do the same thing with
with your show and when you're dealing
with the guys that we deal with look
look Charles Charles changed the
landscape of sports TV for all these
studio shows I mean it was it was never
like this until Charles got here and so
where we didn't have to necessarily talk
about the game if the game wasn't any
good you know we would just we would
just go ahead and and and it's like four
guys sitting in a living room we're
watching the game nobody's asking for
permission to talk and the thing I think
that sticks out is we do not rehearse it
I mean these guys don't go to the
production meeting we don't want them
there you know I have to be there so the
producer and I are on the same page
right but if we want to throw something
at Kenny sometime during the night we
don't want him to have been in the
meeting say okay yeah that'll be funny
and then you say this and I'll laugh and
then you say this and he'll laugh and
then we'll go to break and we don't want
that to happen a lot of times it's
whoever's talking the loudest gets heard
you know it's people interrupting each
other and there are times where I got to
like the guy
please I need that we need to get to
this and but we all love each other I
mean we just we genuinely do and we know
that we're blessed to do what we're
doing I mean we've had this same group
together the three of us for 20 years
and then shack for the last seven and
that doesn't happen in TV because
because executives are always trying to
tinker with the chemistry oh I know who
will work this guy with this guy and
there's no predicting it and so I think
when everybody knows their role and
everybody's satisfied with their role
and nobody's trying to make the show
about them organically things just
happen that the next day people are at
work talking about and saying did you
see when Shaq said he didn't know where
the Golden State Warriors played which
actually happened on our here I'm human
highlights of the Warriors game and I
said we go to Oakland for the highlights
and this is all life and and Shaq just
like Ernie how come you keep saying
Oakland and I was it it's where we're
playing a game I know but why in Oakland
because that's where the Warriors play I
didn't know that and this is why the
highlights are going on I just know we
stayed in San Francisco I got on a bus
you see there's no production meeting in
the world that could come up with let's
do this you know that's just that Shaq
being Shaq and so but that's just it's
just part of what makes the show so much
fun because if you don't know what's
gonna happen
join the club neither do I got no clue
what's gonna happen from one moment to
the next and because it's not rehearsed
you know we'll sit there and start the
show and Charles say I got to say
something and he'll unload and then
suddenly we're talking for three minutes
about that which nobody in the
production meeting ever talked about but
it's just the way the show goes and I
think that's why it's kind of its kind
of resonated with people it's just like
MIT's unpredictable the guys are funny
you never know what they're gonna say
and and if there's gonna be an
international incident that happens and
then sometimes you know we've come maybe
that close to that before I let you go
sir
tell me why the Warriors aren't just
gonna hoist the trophy right now no they
are
I think we know that think but I think
the the thing that always the injury
thing is would always throws a wrench
into things right I mean you know we did
the Western Conference Finals last year
the Houston Rockets could have won that
they could have beaten the Golden State
Warriors but the Chris Paul injury was
huge and so I mean all I can say is if
Golden State's gonna trot out that same
bunch every night from here until until
the finals you can't beat them four
times you know you can try to make it
you can try to make it close you can
play them your best but that's a special
group I mean and now that they've added
DeMarcus Cousins to that mix I mean it's
almost unfair it is almost unfair you
know I suppose look okay you guys have
all these habits you can only play two
of them in this game you know which two
are you gonna play you know that's it's
almost gotten to that point because as
you see right now they've won an 11 in a
row they're just they're just on a roll
Steph Curry's having a tremendous year
and and that's the thing you when you
look at this team yeah maybe Durant will
have an off night maybe Steph will have
an off night maybe they'll have an off
night together and then you just worry
about klay Thompson and DeMarcus Cousins
going off so it's yeah it's it's a
that's the championship team right if
they're healthy if they are healthy for
sure I'm gonna boring the answer to give
you still watch no there's still drama
that is the NBA Anthony Davis coming out
and creating something that right like
you know it looks like we we may have
the first instance of a player accused
of tampering in the NBA I mean do you
think we might get to that point we're
out of silver steps in and there's a
player who owns an agency with an agent
that's shared with the best player
that's come out to say that I want to
get traded no I certainly think it puts
everybody's antenna up in the league
office and you can't let it run rampant
it's gonna be interesting to see how New
Orleans handles this because you can't
wait too long but you don't want to pull
the trigger before you get what you're
what you think he's worth and you don't
want to be stuck with him next year so
if if you don't make a deal by the
star breaking am I saying you have to do
it by the trade deadline this year but
if the time goes on and then suddenly
other teams feel like well maybe we're
right in the rules now because you don't
want to be stuck with them so we're only
gonna give you this it'll be interesting
to see how quickly this this does move
on and if the New Orleans tries to you
know get it done and get top value for
Anthony Davis it's gonna be interesting
an interesting situation but you got
feeling how it works out how it turns
out well it from what I'm hearing about
you know not returning calls from the
Lakers right you know where is a good
place I mean it's Boston a place it all
sits a place that can provide the parts
you can't get the place yeah but no I
don't know I've given up trying to
predict where guys are gonna land or you
know is this guy gonna gonna sign here
that kind of thing I don't know but it's
you know the Laker thing would have been
intriguing but it certainly looks like
the lines of communication are not
exactly open right now
well then outside of your so-called lane
you have a 50th Super Bowl 53 prediction
of how the Patriots in it they are
indeed sir watching him you know
watching him the other day was just you
know it's like just when you and and we
witnessed it when they played the
Falcons in the Super Bowl I am you you
get them down and you know I had
actually stopped watching the game for a
little while with the Falcons up big you
know I started you know cleaning up we
were having a Super Bowl party and I'll
clean some of this stuff up and what's
the score now okay well I'm gonna sit
and watch a little bit more
you just can't ever count them out and
as much as I'd like to see Shawn McVeigh
have a great night he I know he's a he's
a Maris gun there's right nearest high
school here in Atlanta that's right yeah
I went to there a long time before he
did but but I think it'll be I think
it'll be some fun to watch but man that
Patriots have that that it factor man
they do and Ernie Johnson here in the
Honda inside a report which is brought
to you by the all-new Honda Passport the
ruggedly styled SUV that's as capable as
it is stunning heads your Honda dealer
today and see why it's the perfect
vehicle for your adventures love
watching you Ernie and I'm I'm just
thrilled that you came here today my
favorite guy in the business
right here is Rich Eisen gosh that's
good up factory as good as he is at this
he's a better man and so just keep it up
it's always a pleasure to be here when
again I've told you this in on the phone
I'm thrilled to be able to tell you in
person
what you did the night that you won the
Emmy and then called Stewart's kids up
and gave that Emmy - Stuart Scott's
babies was really amazing I think
anybody would have done it but I was I
was thrilled to be in that position to
be able to to honor them and honor Stu
well thank you for doing that you got it
near the mats Ernie Johnson everybody
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience